commence avec une nouvelle journée de
manifestations à paris les soignants se
mobilisent dans le cadre d'une journée
d'action européenne l'objectif défendre
l'accès aux soins pour tous
point de départ de du cortège l'hôpital
la pitié-salpêtrière ailleurs dans toute
l'europe ce sera le cas aussi dans une
dizaine de pays à l'appel d'une
soixantaine d'organisations et parmi les
revendications l'amélioration du système
de santé deux meilleures conditions ils
hausse des salaires on retrouve notre
reporter dans le xiiie arrondissement de
paris david kelly fin avec alexandre
planasse david bonjour le départ de la
manifestation est maintenant prévu pour
14h quelle est l'atmosphère
écoutez la mobilisation à l'appel de
plusieurs collectifs interne hôpitaux se
déroule plutôt bien pour maman la
mobilisation s'annonçait plutôt
importante le départ est donné pour vous
l'avez dire à 14h l'objectif est d' avec
la mer un accès aux soins pour toutes et
pour tous en appel lancé à
l'international afin d'interpeller tous
les gouvernements pour un changement de
politique de santé publique afin de ne
pas revivre à cette crise sanitaire qui
n'a fait qu'accentuer ces inégalités
engendrées à une trop grande dégradation
des fonds le fameux tri des patients
voilà pourquoi la plupart des aides
soignants sont à présent dans la rue
aujourd'hui afin de réclamer aussi une
revalorisation à la hauteur des besoins
de santé à des populations
je vous propose d'écouter quelques uns
des manifestants chaque année nous en
france on a des économies qui sont
faites pour l'hôpital public d'un
milliard à chaque fois on a un budget
qui est deux fois moins important que
les besoins donc à chaque fois on fait
des économies et ça malgré la crise on a
on va continuer dans le même système
on peut pas continuer comme ça on a vu
que c'était important d'avoir un système
de santé fort solidaire ça c'est super
important
une solidarité on a un système de
sécurité sociale on veut le garder on
peut pas partir sur des systèmes
mutualistes comme c'est dans d'autres
pays
sinon ça sera une idée ne savent à
creuser encore les inégalités d'accès
aux soins
et ça c'est dramatique c'est
inacceptable pour des démocraties comme
les nôtres si on fait abstraction des
différences de système de protection
sociale on est tous victimes des mêmes
choses et on dénonce tous les mêmes
choses une santé qui n'est plus à la
hauteur des besoins de la population
dans son capacitaire dans le nombre de
lits dans les hôpitaux par exemple pour
accueillir les patients dans les
effectifs de nos collègues dans les
services pour prendre en charge le
patient est dans la reconnaissance de
nos métiers qui à l'évidence on
sous-estimé sous payés par rapport à des
métiers équivalent dans d'autres dans
d'autres secteurs de l'économie
responsabiliser les élus afin qu'ils
changent réellement les choses à
commencer par une véritable
revalorisation des salaires pour
encourager les jeunes à commencer une
carrière dans les métiers de la santé
le fameux choc d'actes d'attractivité en
tout cas la mobilisation est au rendez
vous pour le moment et devrait se rendre
place de la république à le départ est
donné à 14 heures un dispositif de
sécurité plutôt restreint un bel
objectif vous l'aurez compris c'est
d'interpeller le gouvernement pour ne
plus vivre une crise sanitaire tel cas
là était telle qu'elle a été à durant
cette année
voilà c'est tout tout le message qui
doit être transmis à cet après midi ici
à mercy et david khalifa pour toutes ces
précisions on va vous retrouver dans le
courant de notre prochaine édition